Let's cut to the chase, Ahmed,
and you're a very impressive person
but you're a plastic surgeon.
And this is fascinating
because I think you can see me pretty well
and you've had a good
gander at me over the years.
Were I to have some plastic surgery,
I'm not saying I'm going to,
but let's say I was going
to have plastic surgery
and you were going to do it for free.
(laughter)
These are all just "what if's".
We're not saying anything.
Although I see you nodding
which is kind of an oral agreement.
And keep in mind that this is for free.
So you can give him the budget level work.
Yeah.
Yeah, you can-
[Ahmed] You got it.
You can use plastic spoons to do the work.
And plastic wrap.
Yeah, no, but what did you suggest
or should I leave well enough alone?
I've always heard comedians
need to use their face
and have a certain elasticity.
So I've left this masterpiece alone.
But what do you think?
You called it a Masterpiece?
Well, I'm sorry. I was
just borrowing a phrase
Ahmed was about to use about me.
I don't know if he was.
Picasso
[Ahmed] That's right.
I think he's compiling a list.
Yeah.
Of things he would do to you.
Hieronymus Bosch.
(laughter) Tell me
Ahmed, what would you do?
What would you do?
If I came in and I said,
help me, doc, help me.
Help me with me kisser.
(laughter)
Let's start with some
of your speech first.
Maybe.
Yeah. Why am I talking like
a 1930s guy from Brooklyn?
Hey there, Doc, help me with my kisser.
You gotta help me.
You gotta help me fix me melon.
(laughter) What would
you tell me to do Ahmed?
Well, going back to your
episode with the Davids statue
that you said you would
change to become you.
So you are the standard of beauty.
Thank you.
I don't think there's
much to change, because-
God he's good, I love him.
[Ahmed] You have become the
standard of beauty, right?
I'm the cannon of beauty. Yes. Yes.
But, you know, in a theoretical world-
[Sona] Yes.
I did study some of your later videos,
your recent videos.
Bleh.
[Ahmed] I think, you know-
Nature has been cruel,
time has been cruel to me, Ahmed.
(laughter)
Time has been cruel.
You know,
I think a blepharoplasty or
a little eyelid, you know,
nip/tuck would be good.
What does that do?
[Ahmed] Some Botox in the forehead.
So, you know, what we can do is come in
and get some of the skin
above in your upper eyelid
and we can trim some of
that so it's not, you know-
Skin in the upper eyelid.
Are you noticing,
maybe everyone's, yeah,
get in there close.
Is everyone starting to notice
and doesn't have the guts to tell me?
Gourley? Sona?
When I come in,
do you see tons of folded
skin on my upper eyelids?
No, but if that's how you're
going to end up looking
after this procedure, I
would say maybe don't.
Oh, I don't know.
Yeah, I mean, here's my concern-
I want to stay employed.
And what about, you said
Botox in the forehead area?
Yeah. That would treat those
(indistinct) or wrinkles.
Those lines in the forehead.
Basically it paralyzes
the muscle that we have
in the forehead.
[Sona] You can't do that!
But you see that's the problem.
Here's the problem we're
getting into, Ahmed.
I mean, let's be honest,
as a comedian no one ever hired me
to be the best looking guy in the room
or the youngest looking guy in the room.
They hired me for my
ability to make them laugh
and I've always thought,
well, if I start getting work done,
isn't that going to freeze
this very expressive visage that I have?
It's your moneymaker.
It's your bread and butter
and it's it looks good.
[Sona] Wait, Ahmed, can you-
I got another money maker,
I'll tell you about that.
(laughter)
Can you do something about the eye vein?
Oh, oh, oh! Thank you, Sona.
I have a very prominent eye vein.
And the main vein? I know that.
Okay.
Let's settle down there.
[Matt] Sorry.
You always go to the cock lately
and I don't know what's going on.
[Sona] Oh is that the cock?
I thought he was thinking
about killing you.
You thought about the cock!
What are you doing?
It's all I think about.
All I think about is the cock.
You dirty rascal!
When girlies around
that's where my mind goes.
I don't know why
but no, listen.
Ahmed.
I have a prominent blue vein that runs
under my right eye
And because my skin is, to
use a certain medical term,
completely translucent.
(laughter)
I'm like the statue of the visible woman.
You can see this vein all the time
and I was thinking, you
know, in the past I thought,
what if I got it removed
but it turns out it's feeding
blood to my cerebral cortex.
(laughter)
So I've not meddled with it.
What would you do about that eye vein?
Well I feel like that eye
vein might be the area
that controls making fun of Sona.
Yes.
Oh, then we've got to get it out.
Yeah you're right.`
We've got to get it out.
That's my money maker.
That's my money maker right there.
(laughter)
[Sona] Just kidding.
So other than I'm not
going to get Botox, Ahmed,
because I fear it from my profession.
[Ahmed] Yeah.
My plan is to just let this face melt
in front of America slowly
and sort of as an education to everybody
that this is what happens.
I like that.
To a corpse when it's left in the sun.
How about lip injections?
What? Oh yeah, yeah.
Give him in the ass injections.
Oh, you know what I want to get?
I want to look like Lisa Rinna.
(laughter)
I want to look exactly.
I want to look like Lisa Rinna.
I want to get those crazy lips.
(laughter)
Wouldn't that be fantastic
if I had those giant
crazy, what would you do?
Because I don't have much lip right now.
My mouth is more a like a-
[Ahmed] We could do fillers.
Fuck fillers, let's get Lisa
Rinna to do a transplant
like you would a kidney.
She gives you her lips.
Yeah.
I want Lisa Rinna and I on
side by side operating tables.
(laughter)
And I want her to say just
before she goes under,
I do this for Conan.
And then when she wakes up,
her lips are gone and I
have Lisa Rena's lips.
And then I'm one of the
Desperate Housewives.
[Ahmed] Yeah.
Somehow I think I would
lose my license on that.
That's another thing I
have no ass to speak of.
(laughter)
I keep coming up with more.
No, literally, Sona just keeps, look.
She has a list like Santa's list.
[Matt] Yeah.
It just goes and goes and goes.
I have no butt and it's a curse.
It's in my family.
None of the men have any butt.
So our pants just are always falling off.
(laughter)
And it's a straight drop
from my shoulder right down to my heel.
There's nothing there
to interrupt the drop.
A little tiny man could
jump off my shoulder
and he would fall straight
down to commit suicide.
And he would hit right near my foot.
Carpenters plum.
Yeah. Oh no, I've done it.
I had carpenters come in once
and they hung a carpenter's
plum and it went straight down.
It doesn't sound like those
were carpenters, by the way,
but sure.
No, they weren't carpenters
and you know what?
They gave me a massage
and then they filmed it.
(laughter)
And now it's on Dutch television.
I think you hired the wrong people.
Anyway, Ahmed, here's my question.
What could we do to fill that out?
Because not only do I not have a butt but,
I've described this before,
it actually goes in a little bit.
It's a little bit of a divot
and I keep knickknacks in there.
It's just a little, it's like a shelf.
You have a little concave?
It's concave. It goes the other way.
So is there something or do I
have to go to Brazil for that?
Where do you go to get your butt enhanced?
Can you do that?
Is is called a Brazilian butt lift.
Really?
So what a Brazilian butt lift.
Yeah. That's what it's called.
And what that does is you
take fat by liposuction
from other areas of the body
and you can inject that into the buttocks
in the superficial areas that
are right underneath the skin.
You have to be very careful
because if done incorrectly
it can be very dangerous.
It can lead to bad complications.
Okay. Well, I've got
the best in you Ahmed.
And you're going to be my,
I don't know if you're going to do this.
Hey Ahmed, could you
take Lisa Rinna's lips
and put them on my ass?
Yes and can you do this
remotely where Sona
and I will do the procedure
but you talk us through it.
Yeah. Yeah.
We'll do it over Zoom.
This is actually something
that I've been fantasizing
about is-
Lisa Rinna?
Wait, Lisa Rinna's lips on my ass?
You heard it here.
What's your problem, Ahmed?
You're waking up,
honey, honey, what is it?
That dream where Lisa Rinna's
lips are on Conan's ass.
(laughter)
Wake up, Ahmed.
Wake up, snap out of it.
(laughter)